foreign
how Israel influences British politics
we reveal from the inside how the
Israeli Embassy penetrates different
levels of British democracy and the
first of four programs the battle for
Britain's youth
[Music]
following Decades of violence A new
challenge has emerged to Israel's
occupation of Palestinian lands called
BDS
that's the global movement to boycott
divest and impose sanctions on Israel
and expose it as an apartheid state
the Israeli government has responded
with a campaign to Rebrand the country's
image the reason we should fight BDS is
because it's wrong it's a moral outrage
it's an operation run by the secretive
Ministry of strategic Affairs they
recruit mainly Former Intelligence
offices its main task is to counter BDS
worldwide using an undercover reporter
Al jazeera's investigative unit exposes
Israel's clandestine activities in
London a city that's become a major
Battleground
BDS campaign in many ways germinated in
Britain you
young people working to challenge BDS at
every level of British politics
one of Israel's main targets is the
labor party
for the first time its leader is a
champion of Palestinian civil rights
they'd be very happy to see Jeremy
corbyn no longer leader of the labor
party for sure it's a covert action that
penetrates the heart of Britain's
democracy
down it is outrageous interference in
British politics it shouldn't be
permitted it's a battle of ideas seeking
to change not only how Israel is
portrayed but even how it is debated
[Music]
our undercover reporter grew up in
Germany and creates an identity as a
graduate planning to live in Britain
Robin sets himself up in London as an
aspiring labor party activist with
strong sympathies toward Israel
after over a month of attending party
functions he stood out as a friend of
Israel
and before long he recognized a familiar
face
[Music]
ah okay nice to meet you
it's a meeting of the labor friends of
Israel or lfi
members of the British Parliament who
Lobby for Israel
yeah I take the district
Shai later explained to Robin the
problems the lfi is facing
people want to be Affiliated obviously
window will become MPS they won't be
Affiliated and then that's it Chinese is
done because for years every MP to
joined the final man the third thing
that he used to do is going to join
another fight he's not doing it anymore
they're doing it automatically
[Music]
all of the 14 new MPS I just got in the
last elections all of the ones today see
if I could talk as well okay yeah
but you need to get more people on board
it's a lot of work actually
Robin tweeted and wrote articles about
Israel in the labor party building up
his online identity
he discovered numerous groups that
support Israel and which identify
themselves as independent Grassroots
movements one is the Sussex friends of
Israel
[Applause]
they organized a march to protest
against the pro-palestinian movement to
boycott Israel
[Applause]
[Music]
Aubin had joined them
[Music]
shy later described the embassy's role
in some of these movements there is a
Grassroots organization as a Sussex
friends of Israel that directed
demonstration it was it's very great an
alliance there is a Viper there is so
many people live in Israel with so many
Shai had helped establish a youth group
within the conservative friends of
Israel they have a young section of the
Gazette
see if I start
Ed
because of my idea and then when I tried
to do this the same in the labor they
had a crisis that that was forming
every group yeah
specifically elephant young people it
doesn't exist the only place
the moment it will become to 100 people
200 people
then it started to become real
organization but just to take a year
have you ever built something like a
group
yeah I did several things like that yeah
okay as well I'm here I'm here as well
nothing today I can share but yeah
something to share yeah because there
are things that you know happened but we
are
it's good to leave those organizations
independent but we help them yeah
hey thank you very much have a nice
evening all right
our investigation linked the embassy
senior political officer with a series
of pro-israel groups
the Parliamentary friends of Israel
young conservatives lobbyists as well as
Grassroots movements
in addition shy is involved with the
youth arm of the Fabian Society an
influential labor party Think Tank
he's a good friend of mine
[Music]
when we engage with the Israel Embassy
they gave us a program that was very
neutral and you know I know I met shy
for the process and and shy you know in
himself he's very much he's very
balanced guy and if you talk to his or
Embassy they're not going to baraju
propaganda
it appears the Israeli diplomats mission
is to build support for Israel at all
levels of the labor party
those are other groups that are
educating them peace
Shai says he knows nearly all the Fabian
Society activists
[Music]
almost all of them yeah
[Music]
Martin edibar explains how foreign
government support helps the Fabian
membership she
Sharon he's got great contact on both
and in Israel as part of these public
experience he's a great guy as well he's
a he's very he's very helpful and very
supportive as well and he's very
balanced
I went on one of the trips of the
conservative friends of Israel to the
Middle East
brilliantly well arranged very well
looked after you've got fantastic access
you did meet Palestinians if all you did
was rely on that one trip you would have
a very one-sided point of view recently
I saw something
like something really I think that you
know the Israelis are not giving weren't
given Palestinians quarter or something
during Ramadan I know that's false
according to hot Eric's newspaper Israel
which controls all water sources in the
occupied West Bank did cut supplies even
if the reason was contested I've been to
Israel going to the delegation seeing
what systems actually like I know that's
false
but you only will understand that if you
actually go to the country our
undercover reporter discovered that shy
massage played a role in another key
labor party organization the Jewish
labor movement or JLM
Robin attended a summer barbecue
organized by the JLM
much of the small talk turned to the
Israeli Embassy
um shy are you no shy yeah oh how
interesting I won't be shy oh you worked
for sure
I wanted to also kind of formally
welcome Ella to her new posters uh
director
[Music]
I'll Always by no means the person on
that part of CVS that had the most labor
party and political experience
but there was something that we felt on
the JLM executive and his trustees
mattered far more which is that she's
one of you she's seen this stuff from
the inside she's fought the campus
battles alongside you which is why we
took the step of appointing power to
this role because we think she's going
to go on and play an incredibly
critical role at the lead and the
struggle against 80 70s in the labor
party
foreign
let's go out let's change the labor
party for the better and let's hopefully
influence the future of this
country for the better with a you know
Progressive strong
Fair Society
[Applause]
thank you
what came next surprised our undercover
reporter
Robin to become part of the Israeli
embassy's plan to attract young labor
party members
[Music]
the idea is to establish a kind of
approach that we work with young people
so what I'm saying is that if you're a
fitter and you would like to get engaged
yeah I guess they're looking for someone
that you really need to know
we need to try to think about so what
can you do
shy then suggested that as well as
setting up the young lfi Robin apply for
a job at the Israeli Embassy
he was invited to a private meeting at a
London hotel
it included Embassy staff and British
supporters of Israel
an Israeli Diplomat takes Robin to one
side
we're looking for workers for someone to
work at the embassy I don't know if it's
something my interest here
besides told me about that actually so I
handed in my CV that'll be it that's it
exactly we're also looking for somebody
to work on the whole BDS to be doing
research with the different PDF
movements who they are what they are a
little bit of strategy on that hopefully
I don't know if either of those things
might appeal to
Ella Rose the new director of the Jewish
labor movement was pleased to hear of
Robin's plans to set up a young lfi
please consider me your number
the guest of honor a minister from the
Israeli government
[Music]
totally belongs to the Jewish people not
any compromised morally biblically the
land of Israel belongs to the Jewish
people
[Music]
the primary role of Israel's strategic
Affairs Ministry is to counter the BDS
movement
for the future of Israel because if we
will allow them to continue with all the
life that they are spreading against
Israel we will lose this fantastic Young
Generation and maybe from here there
will be the next leader of the UK or
other countries and they will think that
Israelis are very bad country
foreign
another meeting with the embassy's
senior political officer shy tutors
Robin on setting up a new pro-israel
group
s
how do you approach them so first of all
I think you need something to sell
right historically maybe if I would
agree to do a delegation to itself
that's always a good start second maybe
you need an interesting speaker
that's maybe the embassy can help or
anything else if you're a volunteering
you know to be the
chairman of it he theoretically needs to
have somewhere to do social media and
someone that will take care of speakers
or events or someone that will be the
chairman of the delegations to Israel
and then you just you know and then
people becoming then you have a
structure then it's not just your
responsibility because it's one of you
another six people who are
responsibility somehow and they're the
committee of that organization
and that's it that's doing your
substance organization
who should I contact what do you think
[Music]
what's his position in the NFL
he's a parliamentarian officer
labor party before that
students a new shy in my world I live as
soon as we did a couple of things
together
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the lfi appears to be looking Beyond
Labor's present set of MPS
not only a good place to say release
yeah good views on Israel and I think we
haven't really paid much attention to
those people you know people are going
to be in Parliament in 10 15 years time
Robin tells him about the Israeli
embassy's interest in recruiting him
yeah
he gave an example of how a job at the
embassy could further a career in
British politics
president of ejs which is the union
energy students a couple years ago we've
seen the work there we ever seen but
she's leaving with Embassy to work of
Jewish labor movements
[Music]
new guards came in and they sort of
thought at some point okay we're gonna
hire someone to like help with stuff
and then all the anti-Semitism
Christopher and they thought
probably higher small theater
doing before that okay
around about the same time the JLM
re-emerged under the leadership of
Jeremy Newmark who would later hire
elrose as the Director of the JLM the
big story was about a young student in
Oxford who made allegations that the
labor party and most of the student left
at Oxford was anti-semitic he didn't
present any evidence at all the only
thing he said was that they had promoted
the Israel apartheid week which is a
well-known event which takes place on
campuses around the world the national
chairman of Labor students at that time
was Michael Rubin so allegations
so I did the investigations last year
I'm labor students
as labor students what we like about
some people for also asking questions
about it because that was kind of the
first instance of antimicism
and there was lots of media leaks and
talks about
how anti-Semitism was being covered up
British newspapers repeatedly ran
stories of anti-Semitism in the labor
party
one of the next targets was Malia buatia
the newly elected leader of Britain's
National Union of students
foreign
foreign
with each year of Israel's expanding
occupation support for BDS has spread on
college campuses around the world in
Britain the israeli-palestinian conflict
defined the 2016 election for the nus
presidency
Israel where it exists now is that
problematic to you
Israel as it behaves is problematic to
me
you would feel it would be okay for you
to say about yourself that you are
anti-zionist yes I would
Robbie Young
malius and U.S president Robbie he's one
of the vice presidents
he's a labor student and he's like
really good in this world and he's been
out on a trip so you've seen Israel
until we've seen it firsthand
so there are some people at nus which
yeah
another vice president Richard Brooks
took the unusual step of publicly
claiming that buatya's criticisms of
Israel amount to anti-semitism
when you look at what demolia has been
saying she says it's her criticisms are
a political one she talks about Zionism
not about people who are Jewish yeah I
think the really important thing here
and something that the student movement
needs to face up to is that it is for
Jewish students to to find what
anti-Semitism is and in the run-up to
National Conference nearly 50 Union of
Jewish student presidents of societies
made it clear that they had concerns
about some of the rhetoric Brooks never
mentioned that weeks before that
interview he'd been taken to Israel as
part of a delegation from the union of
Jewish students
taking on the trip to Israel with UJS
but yeah obviously yeah
during the run-up to the election
Richard Brooks had held private meetings
with Russell Langer the campaign
director of the Union of Jewish students
also attending the meetings was Michael
Rubin
when he was Cheryl maybe she's asking my
words it was me him and the muscle yes
I've made him work quite classic last
year after being introduced by the
Israeli Embassy as a young lfi volunteer
our undercover reporter explores the
possibility of ousting the
pro-palestinian and U.S president with
the help of Richard Brooks how can we
get in touch with the people who are
trying to oppose her you speak to me
because I'm helping organize them yeah
so okay cool so just drop by whatever
you want to have a conversation or if
you want to speak to someone inside a
geographic Aquarium
[Music]
our investigation also revealed that the
union of Jewish students who sent
critics of Malia buatia on trips to
Israel has received money from the
Israeli Embassy
gives money to um
in 2016 Shapiro launched an unsuccessful
bid for the presidency of the Union of
Jewish students
he also received donations from Israel
to set up a new campus-based Think Tank
he established the pinsker center with
former University College student
Elliott Miller
foreign
he's a genius
they also confirmed for the first time
that the powerful American pro-israel
Lobby aipac is channeling money to
British campuses through the pinsker
center
we went to APAC in March
Elliot Miller remains vocal in The
Cauldron of London student politics
present another narrative
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
episode 2 further evidence of Israel's
involvement in Britain's labor party
foreign
and the money Israel gives labor and
peace to help improve its image it's
more than one